my colleague matt walsh
matt is a beloved women's studies
scholar he is the leading uh
lgbtq plus children's author in the
country
and amazon is very upset about this
amazon we knew this months ago
amazon had been trying to suppress
matt's book johnny the walrus
a story about a confused little boy who
thinks that he's a walrus and whose
society encourages him to believe that
he's a walrus
so the book did very very well when it
first came out
but amazon tried to suppress it and as
always when the libs go in and they get
exposed trying to suppress something it
skyrockets to the top of the chart so i
think for for a little while yesterday
matt actually had two best-selling books
on the charts it's his upcoming book
what is a woman and then the the
children's book that actually came out a
while ago a a whistleblower at amazon
leaked the footage of amazon conspiring
to suppress johnny the walrus
it's been a very traumatic experience
for transgender amazonians and our
transgender customers johnny the walrus
is
a bit of a problematic book
uh not a bit it is
it is not a bit of a problem it's one
hell of a problem
you are selling a manual
how to teach kids to bully other kids to
commit suicide
i talked to she said she was going to
get the book stripped off of your site
now he is bragging
that he has the number one book you are
still going to continue to sell it and
now he's bragging
and that he's glad it's going to make
the lgbtqia
kids especially transgenders
commit suicide so because matt walsh
said that little boys can't become
walruses
lgbtq kids
even that whole concept is extremely
problematic the idea that five-year-olds
have this distinct sexual identity
even moving past that for a second the
idea is that because matt walsh made a
book about how a little kid can't become
a walrus that now kids are going to
commit suicide because of him
and amazon's taking this lunatic woman
seriously saying yes you're oh wow
that's so we have to do something we
need to try to suppress matt one way or
the other and of course when this comes
out what happens the people want to buy
this book
the book was very popular
the idea is very popular look look what
happened at twitter
when elon musk came in and said we are
going to have free speech at that
platform
something changed overnight i've gained
something like 70 000 twitter followers
in the last four days three or four days
other people are some some other people
are reporting even larger gains is it
just bots i don't think it's just bots
because a lot of these new followers are
blue check marks they're people who are
supposedly verified getting a lot more
engagement something changed in the way
that twitter is working to allow
conservatives overnight to have a lot
more engagement have a much wider reach
on the platform it would seem to me that
that is
a easing up on the suppression of
conservatives
despite the best ebert's efforts of the
liberal censors
people still know some basic truths i'm
glad you liked that clip now
ding ding ding ring that bell subscribe
get all the notifications for the
michael knowles show you can also head
on over to apple podcast spotify stitch
or google play wherever you get your
audio podcast subscribe to the michael
knowles show we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you